[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and I've censored
two of the most controversial prisoners
in the UK both vying for freedom
first he spent four years in a British
jail and could face a lifetime of
Maximum Security in the United States
but the debate still rages is Julian
Assange a whistleblower or a terrorist
I've talked to his father and his
brother
plus Charles Bronson arguably the most
notorious prisoner in British history
loses another bid for Freedom today
to his lawyers ever killed anyone will
he ever be let out also tonight British
schools allow children to change their
genders without even informing their
parents our kids being put at risk by
policies of welcome
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening for London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored if
your son or daughter got into a
Fighter's School you probably want to
hear about it I know I would the same
would apply if they were being bullied
or falling behind in class clearly
parents have a right to know what's
happening in their children's lives so
they can offer support in whatever way
they can so what about if your child
decides to transition to another gender
you probably want to know about that
wouldn't you I've had four kids I'd want
to know but it turns out that a shocking
number of schools in Britain think you
as parents have no right to know that
children are being allowed to change
their names their uniforms and their
personal pronouns that dreaded phrase
using different toilers and changing
rooms without their parents having a
clue about any of this happening does 39
of 304 schools investigated by the
policy exchange Think Tank said they
informed parents if their own child said
they wanted to change gender in many
cases parents only found out when they
got alleged from the post citing their
child's new name and new pronouns as a
point of fact think about that that's
how the parents found out that kids had
decided to change their gender and their
name most School surveys said they're
actively teaching the contested theory
that children may have a different
gender than their biological sex this is
completely outrageous it's policy driven
by fear of the woke mob something I've
talked about many times but this is what
I'm talking about schools are so afraid
of being eviscerated they're not
tolerating the latest whim of gender
ideology that they're failing in their
duty to both parents and the kids
scandals up at Tavistock Clinic remember
that where hundreds of children were
handed puberty blockers just by having
other in most cases other complicated
mental health problems so the importance
of getting this right children with
gender dysphoria need intensive care and
support from adults with their best
interests but we shouldn't be afraid to
point out that many of them might have
other problems Others May Simply Be Gay
gender identity has become a fad a craze
virtually unheard of a few decades ago
it's almost unavoidable in schools today
when things in our society change this
much this fast we have a right to at
least discuss it and parents should be
at the very heart of that conversation
but we'll debate that later in the
program the first it's been 20 years
since the invasion of Iraq rightly or
wrongly feuded more to call attention to
the conduct of U.S military in that war
than the WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange Wikileaks made Global headlines
in 2010 by publishing leaked classified
files and evidence of war crimes
fighting extradition to the U.S in 157
years in a maximum security jail Assange
took refuge in the Ecuadorian Embassy he
was arrested after emerging and has now
spent four years four years in belmarsh
prison probably the toughest prison in
the country supporters say he's a free
speech Champion who's shown a light on
Military brutality critics think he's
nothing less than a terrorist who
threatened National Security
my name is John Shipton I'm Julian
assange's father
Wikileaks found that Julian Assange has
been arrested one of the most notorious
and controversial figures in custody
since we'll remain Behind Bars until
that extradition hearing which has been
set down for the end of February
I urge the Department of Justice to drop
the charges
the maximum jail sentence of 175 years
[Music]
well I'm joined Now by Julian's Father
John Shipton and his brother Gabriel
Shipton who've made that new documentary
film on their fight to secure during the
sanji's release along with security and
terrorism expert we'll get it so welcome
to all of you thank you very much to the
shiptons uh who are joining me from
America let me start with you John
Shipton you're Julian's dad it must be
regardless of the debate that we're
about to have about this incredibly
tough for a father
to see a son a child incarcerated for so
long without any apparent conclusion to
these legal proceedings in belmarsh
which I've been to which is one of the
toughest prisons in the country
oh it appears it's very difficult and
the circumstances of Julian's declining
Health make the the matter dire and
critical
some
Julian is allowed a 10-minute phone call
to me
daily I haven't spoken today but the day
before yesterday we had a 10 minute
conversation
how would you categorize his State of
Mind
uh well it goes up and down generally
not good but as we report upon the
journey across the United States and
then the enthusiasm with which we're
greeted this is heartening for Julian
and uh lifts his spirits considerably
you know you know John I've been a
journalist for more than three decades
I've run big newspapers in the UK I've
covered this story obviously extensively
and I watched a movie the other day
again in preparation for this interview
actually just to remind myself of the
whole story as it all played out and a
large part of me has a lot of Sympathy
For What Julian Assange did you know he
exposed some really serious things and
he did it in a Fearless way there's no
question of that but a to be also when I
was reminded of this felt that his
actions in in the way he did it could
well be categorized as Reckless just
putting everything out there seemed to
me something which for example as
narrator of a newspaper we would never
have been able to do
um did you when you saw what he did did
you have qualms as his father that that
particular action in just putting it all
out
was uh was something that was always
going to get him into this kind of
trouble
oh please you know first place I have to
accept your assertion and just putting
it all out which is uh if you forgive me
for saying so quite directly incorrect
the uh there were a hundred Media
Partners uh with Julian uh each of them
responsible for a particular area all of
this was covered in the hearing that the
reductions the ultimate release of all
of the cables
unredacted was done by
kryptone.org John Young site in New York
okay let me bring
it Gabriel Gable Julian's your
half-brother you've made this film you
guys because you're desperate to try and
get him out I guess of prison
how is that going what reaction are you
getting particularly in America
well we're getting very emotional
reactions here in the U.S where about
halfway through a 59 event tour around
the United States
people are enraged when they realize
what's going on uh how their rights are
at stake in in Julian's persecution
people after we do showings people come
up to us and say you know thank you for
doing this thank you for standing up for
our first amendment in the United States
so it's it's really breathtaking that
audiences around the US are really
beginning to understand what's at stake
for them in this in this case their
Democratic right to know what
governments do in their name
uh back in October I interviewed uh John
Bolton he was a former U.S national
security advisor of course and he said
this to me
he's committed clear criminal activity
he's no more a journalist than the chair
I'm sitting on the information that he
divulged did in fact put many people in
Jeopardy it undercut the ability of the
United States to have confidential
diplomatic Communications and I hope he
gets at least 176 years in jail for what
he did it's a very strong words there
Gabriel
um and that is if you shared by a lot of
Americans there's no question
particularly in the political sphere on
the Republican side certainly who
believe that what your brother did
was bordering on treason what do you say
to that
well everything that Julian published it
was in the public interest and he
partnered with these media organizations
as John said so you're talking about all
the the largest Prestige media
organizations around the world who
published the exact same information uh
people uh like John Bolton they would
like to be able to classify everything
so that the public had no idea what that
what the governments that they elected
were getting up to and I think it's
particularly in the United States now
you're seeing a larger and larger
movement for government accountability
people understanding that a
classification of documents is is uh
totally uh overused you know Joe Biden's
has classified documents in the boot of
his Corvette Trump has classified
documents in the basement of Mar-A-Lago
this overclassification of documents so
that the public doesn't understand then
what the government is doing
is really a problem for democracy and
you have to ask ourselves
knowing about what our government does
in our name is is our right and our
Democratic right and do we want to live
in a democracy or do we want to live in
a tyranny where governments act with
impunity in secrecy uh and no
accountability accountability
accountability let me bring in will get
us now who's a security expert will be
spoken about this before but what is
your reaction to this because it is a
complex issue you know my my
journalistic side believes in free
speech I believe a lot of what Wikileaks
exposed was absolutely in the public
interest but I do think there are also
legitimate concerns about the sheer
amount of material that was put out
there which could well have put lives in
Jeopardy what do you think about it
well appears I'd agree with you entirely
I think uh there are some aspects of the
information that wasn't released by
acknowledge which was in the public
interest but public interest is a very
subjective word or term there is
information that does require
confidentiality I I work with
confidential information on a daily
basis and that information has to be
secured for a variety of a very wide
spectrum of reasons and one of the
greatest concerns is there was simply a
release of information that was not
filtered necessarily I believe in the
public interest and when we talk about a
democracy and about there being access
to certain information that democracy
can be undermined by that information or
certain information being protected now
I do believe in whistleblowers and I do
believe that there is a reason and also
purpose for whistleblowing but there was
information that assault was responsible
for whether he had acquired it himself
or he was publishing it on behalf of
other parties is the problem is is as
the disseminator of that information he
was putting a lot of National Security
particularly in the United States at
Great risk and also other members of
obviously the intelligence community and
that was putting lives at risk that's
what we've got to bear in mind it wasn't
just uncovering atrocities or misuses of
power this was information that helps us
keep our country safe against the bad
guys the terrorists out there who want
to find out about how those instruments
of intelligence are used and what is
available to them
we bring back in John Shipton John in
January President Biden was accused of
hypocrisy for demanding the release of
journalists detained around the world
while he continues seeking the
extradition of your son what did you
think of that
oh you know
if I could just address a few of the
items that were rattled off there as
though their the as though the the
utterings of truth they're simply not
Robert E Gates the Secretary of Defense
and testimony to the the Congress the
stated
categorically under eyes that it was
awkwardly embarrassing but no damage was
done General Carr giving evidence at the
trial of Chelsea Manning stated equally
categorically under oath nobody was hurt
so those assertions that people make
founded upon Conjuring up Ghosts of Fear
the all of government
investigation in the Australian
government made the same similar
declaration no laws were broken so those
statements where people conjure up fears
that something may have happened
something may be happen in the future
and this and that was in danger as
simply baseless assertions
rather loudly denying the fact that
there are crimes involved in this and
they point to the fact that maybe
somebody's endangered when the 400
000 Iraq war files
revealed clearly
that fifteen thousand civilian deaths
had been gone unreported
and what is it with these people that
can't address the matter of what the
files actually reveal and deal with that
and then if the if they feel that
certain Secrets have been uh
uncomfortable then cause the United
States and supernet to look after their
own
secrets rather than blaming Julian and
Chelsea Manning these people can't
manage their own secrets
for God's sake man
John
um you sound weary from this you sound
exhausted uh fighting this battlefield's
son how do you think this ends
oh you know you just uh appears uh deal
with each day as it comes and try and
keep a bit calm it's in early morning
here so I never good in the mornings I I
after midday I Rouse up a bit but the
ending will be
the Yearning For Justice in people's
heart and the revulsion that Injustice
will prevail in this matter millions of
people around the world join us every
single Civil Society organization in the
United States of standing has written 27
of them have written to Biden asking for
the charges to be dropped sorry turmeric
Garland the the the the of the doj
Department of Justice asking for the the
five Great media Legacy newspapers that
partner in this distribution of these
Revelations the the New York Times the
guardian the el pay in Spain and Le Mans
under Spiegel in Germany
of equally written to the Department of
Justice head Mary Garland and asked for
the the charges to be dropped the
phenomenon and the problem is global and
the phenomenon and the problem is
addressed globally by people concerned
with this Injustice John and Gabriel
thank you both very much indeed for
joining me uh the passion is clear and
the battle goes on and we'll thank you
very much indeed for joining me as well
I appreciate it
notorious prisoner to another today
Charles Bronson's had yet another bid
for Freedom rejected he insists he's not
a threat to the public he's ever killed
anybody and yet he's still in prison
after five decades he may never come out
is that right is that fair is certainly
notorious he's certainly been very
dangerous is he now I'll talk to his
lawyer after the break
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read the book
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
you're thinking it we're talking about
[Music]
well he's been dubbed Britain's most
violent prisoner and today Charles
Bronson failed in his eighth attempt to
be released on parole in almost 50 years
in jail he staged nine rooftop protests
10 sieges holding at least 11 victims
hostage he's never actually killed
anybody so notorious is he's even had a
filmmate of his life Tom Hardy played
him in the Twin 2009 movie Bronson and
then a voice note from prison which he
made this week Bronson insisted that he
loves people and isn't a threat
foreign
love the world
I'm not a filthy cherished or a rapist
we're a murderer
so we're more dangerous to our joy
more dangerousness was in the prison
ERS Charles Bronson's lawyer Dean
Kingdom for his first interview since
this latest parole move failed again
Dean is he ever going to be that out do
you think well we certainly hope so
Piers the test for the parole board is
is it necessary for the protection of
the public that he remains confined
obviously this time around the probe
would have decided that he does
remain dangerous but the the issue for
us peers is very much this the parole
board are only limited to looking at
release or open conditions he's a
category a prisoner in a prison in the
prison now the only person that can
progress him through that system is
Dominic Robb and there's a lack of
political will certainly in his case to
make that progress I'm a little on the
face of it for someone who's never
killed anyone it does seem extraordinary
these had to spend most of five decades
now in prison it's just when you get
into the weeds of why they keep
rejecting his parole it starts to to
understand the other side of this you
know he was originally in jail for seven
years years in the early 70s for armed
robbery he got let out twice but both
times was back in prison within weeks on
other robbery offenses he said seven
failed attempts at parole as we said but
he was given seven years in 1994 for
false imprisonment of blackmail in 1997
took a deputy prison Governor staff for
three inmates hostage and got five years
in 2000 he got a life sentence for
kidnapping a prison art teacher Phil
Danielson in whole prison the previous
year the 43 hour ordeal Mr Danielson was
beaten stabbed death with panic attacks
and PTSD and has never worked again over
the course of his incarceration as we
said nine rooftop protests 10 hostage
sieges 11 victims in 2014 further
centered to three more years resulting
another prison Governor Adrian Wallace
held him hostage for five hours and tied
him up and beat him there was a long
long Litany of appalling incidents and
violence against people trying to run
prisons
um in some people's lives being
completely ruined so yes it's true he
hasn't killed anyone but he's clearly
been extremely dangerous he's got this
reputation for a reason of course and
we've never we've never sought to
portray him any differently but the the
why would he be safe on the outside now
well the argument that one of the
witnesses made at the parole hearing was
he's actually more risky and dangerous
in prison towards prison Governors and
staff than he would be in the community
how do you know that well the probe
would never know the prob would be
looking at Future how do you know that
as his lawyer because I mean it's to
have so many incidents of extreme
violence kidnapping people falsely
imprisoning them torturing them and so
on I mean it doesn't sound like you
could have that much confidence and if
he got on the outside and somebody wound
him up the wrong way he wouldn't do this
kind of thing to people on the outside
some of the evidence that the parole
board heard during the hearing was the
motivation and his progress is the best
it's ever been the next step the next
test is to progress him within the
prison to enable him to mix with more
prisoners and in a less harsh regime
when was he last of Ireland 2018 five
years ago there's been no violence no
violence for fire do you think he's a
genuinely changed character or does he
just want to get out he's or both it's a
mixture of both it's self-motivated
interest he's reached an age now where
he knows if he steps out of line in the
future and commits an act of violence
he's dying in prison but the test the
test for him will be progressed in the
system and the thing is appears he's in
a Cell 23 hours a day he's supposed to
have an hour of psychology a week
so in the last year you would expect at
least 52 sessions he's had 13 and the
reason for that isn't his behavior his
resources the prison he's in is
significantly understandable who has you
know terrorized prison officers and
Waters
you know why should he be given any
better treatment frankly I mean he's
he's persistently done that until as you
say five years ago but for four decades
he was terrorizing people in prison but
it's not better treatment he's in a
prison in a prison so the two the two
limbs for someone to be put into that
Arena now is risk to prisoners or staff
or persistently disruptive behavior well
as we established at the parole here and
he's not engaging in persistently
disruptive behavior and in actual fact
the prison service and the authorities
have reduced his risk to staff to medium
which is the lowest it's ever been now
one of the arguments Dominic ra put
forward at the parole hearing was he's a
high risk of serious harm to the public
therefore that means he cannot be
released but the system and the reality
is nine out of ten lifers are released
as high risk of serious harm so right
and as he said and he's got some point
to this he's not a terrorist he's not a
rapist he's not a murderer he's not any
of the conventional kinds of criminal a
lot of his crimes really are inside
prison against people that work there is
not to justify them at all it's just to
compare them to perhaps other people who
are being let out on a regular basis you
can kill people and be let out within 12
years right
oh yeah in some circumstances but I
think we have to look more globally at
the parole system this week uh Dominic
was introduced the victims and prisoners
bill which is going to enable him to
stack the parole board full of law
enforcement officers and there's
credibility issues with police officers
at the moment but parking that aside he
wants the ability to veto paroleable
decisions so then we're looking at
what's the point of the parole board
it's utterly absurd
what's your message to Dominic rather my
message to Dominic Robb is he's got
enough going on in his own with his own
role as Deputy PM he's under
investigation himself
in any other profession he wouldn't he
wouldn't remain in a job whilst being
investigated he'd be suspended yet here
he wants to interfere with the
independence of the parole board which
is a cult but only last only last week
the high court handed down judgment
saying
um a major piece of parole board
guidance that he issued around
recommendations from his own staff
preventing them was ruled unlawful now
it was only in Charlie's case that the
Witnesses were able to give
recommendations he wanted to silence
them all not allow him to make
recommendations and the high court has
said that's Mass contempt to call how
much of the problem that your client has
is to do with his notorious reputation
which he has gleefully fueled over the
years let's be clear how much of that
notoriety is perhaps the reason he's
still inside in other words if we didn't
really know much about him and he just
did all this under the public radar
would he be out by that well it
significantly contributed but we need to
shine a light on What's called the close
supervision Center that's the prison
within the prison it's very difficult to
get
um out of that system do you go and see
him in there yeah of course how often do
you see him um on average once every six
to eight weeks and well I mean how is he
what's he like I only know what I've
read I I mean personally I've never felt
at risk from him never and I say that
having previously he's taken his lawyers
uh hostage but you know he's for someone
who's spent so long in solitary
confinement and that's what it is he's
actually
um very down to earth and very with it
I think he surprised the parole board
the parole boarder expected over the
course of three days into present in a
slightly different way and of course he
handled the pressure of the situation
very well have you spoken to him since
his latest parole what's happening I
have and that what was his reaction his
reaction look he's realistic he
understands that for the parole board to
release someone who's uh CSC but also
category a it's a big step so he's
focused on the next review and our next
challenge and our next challenge firmly
rests with the secretary of state
Dean Kingdom thank you very much for
joining me I appreciate it well coming
up is one of the journalists who exposed
big Tech censorship at Twitter after
being asked to investigate by Elon Musk
with his owner what he found about the
Cozy relationship between government and
big Tech should worry anyone who cares
about Free Speech I'll be speaking to
him next
[Music]
thank you
very beloved and let us Pride so careful
we're praying too exactly this is like
some kind of Submarine prime minister
you're making the case here now a MILF
stands for mother I'd like to I'm not
going to say the next word pop the
kettle on this is the royal tea did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
hahaha
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're talking about
foreign this is talk TV
[Music]
well when Elon Musk bought Twitter last
year he invited several independent
journalists to be the social networks HQ
to look through its archives their
findings are being published as a
Twitter files and the journalists say
they show that the likes of Twitter
Facebook and Google or anything but
independent they claim they're actually
a state sponsor thought police blocking
people and stories at the request of the
US government Security Services even big
Pharma companies here is Twitter files
journalist Matt Tabu testifying to U.S
Congress earlier this year
indictments aren't a thing to do you
disagree there are about 40 or 50 pages
do you disagree with the evidence
outlined in those indictments
well indictments are just charges
do you disagree with the evidence
included in those indictments yes or no
and I understand it's a pretty detailed
allegations in the Mueller indictment by
the way you should go read the
indictment and then come back and tell
us if you actually think there's no
proof of it well let me move on let me
move on please by the way please let me
move on that's how this works you should
know that by now
so being bossed around there Matt Toby
joins me now uh Matt um I watched some
of that and it was you know entirely
predictable I think the way that you
were roughed up there but at the core of
this when you went through all the
Twitter files as it being called what
was your main takeaway from what had
been going on
well I think the the point of that
exchange uh between myself and uh and
first of all happy birthday appears
thank you very much thank you
um uh so that was Congressman Dan
Goldman from New York and he was uh
essentially giving me a hard time
because the premise of a lot of uh the
digital censorship in America is that we
had this overwhelming uh threat of
Russian interference in the American
informational system and he was trying
to get me to agree that that was the
case and that therefore censorship is
Justified and that's one of the things
that we found in the Twitter files is
that there's widespread uh communication
between companies like Twitter Facebook
and Google and agencies like the FBI and
DHS and the predicate for all of this is
that there's a big foreign threat but
mostly they're policing domestic speech
right and that's I mean some really
interesting stuff was going on with this
phrase Shadow Banning for those who
don't know what shadow Banning is just
give me a quick explanation and then how
much of it did you find
oh a lot yeah so Shadow Banning is is
just these companies have the ability to
basically dial all the way up to
um you know sort of massively Amplified
or dial all the way down to uh
unsearchable uh anybody's social media
presence and if you look on the
individual pages of people and we got a
chance to do that in the cases of some
high profile accounts you'll see that
they'll be labeled with things like that
say things like Trends Blacklist or
search blacklist which means that you
your name can't be searched or you can
only be searched by people who follow
you or people who follow you can't
search you they have a thousand
different gradations that they can do
and this allows them to come more or
less completely control how visible each
person is compared to anybody else you
know what was really fascinating to me
was I wrote a best-selling book or wake
up and it did really well but the entire
period that it was on sale my Twitter
following
slowly went down over the whole of most
of last year 2022 just kept going down I
really annoyed me I was like it's weird
and over the space of about eight nine
months I lost about 50 000 followers I
thought how can I have this best-selling
book and my Twitter following has always
been going up and up and up and up into
millions millions millions I mean
suddenly it all started going the other
way and then when I read all your
investigation well that makes perfect
sense because Twitter was being
basically run by a bunch of very woke
people you probably thought my book
exposing the Ridiculousness of wokery
would be the enemy to them and I think
they're up to all sorts of tricks with
me because the moment Elon Musk bought
Twitter at the end of October last year
from that period to now far from going
down I've gained about 600 700 000 new
followers
um so clearly something was going on I'm
just one of many people but that right
there was evidence to me that I was
being somehow suppressed right to the
point Elon bought the company
yeah and that's not an uncommon story we
heard lots of people I mean I myself uh
my follower account was sort of at the
same place for a long time I didn't
particularly bother me but then
suddenly I woke up one day and it
started going back up again we did see
in the Twitter files uh absolutely for
sure there were instances where they
were saying this person is already being
de-amplified or this this account is
already being Amplified so we know that
they they were doing that in some cases
it's algorithmic and in some cases they
were actually there was a human being
going in and tinkering with the
Machinery with individual accounts so
without knowing what was going on with
your account
um you know it could could be either one
of those things right
since elon's taking it over obviously
he's got lots of problems and challenges
he's trying to work through and I've got
every confidence he will he's shown that
in the past with other companies but
what are the particular challenges do
you think he faces now I mean if you
were I know I mean you have been
advising him but what are the things he
really needs to get a grip of with
Twitter do you think to make it a fairer
playing field
well I I don't really advise them um you
know I think that's not a relationship
that that um that I have with him but
you know I think his purpose with the
Twitter files uh was to try to restore
some credibility to the platform uh a
lot of people had a lot of suspicions
about things that were going on sort of
underneath the surface surface of social
media companies and the idea of letting
this all out in the open was to say yes
these things these things were happening
Shadow bending was happening uh people
were being deleted uh this was being
done at the behest of governments and
various uh ngos and think tanks for
getting people taken off these platforms
now people know that for sure maybe we
can start over and and create a new
system that's more transparent I think
that was the idea behind the project and
I you know I I hope it's been successful
I mean the most egregious most egregious
example I can think of and I wrote about
this at the time it happened was just
before the last election when the New
York Post who I wrote a column for uh
they had this big expose there about
Hunter Biden's laptop the son of the
president had a laptop full of pretty
contentious stuff but potentially
criminal stuff
um certainly the public interest to
reveal this and it was all completely
accurate and genuine and yet Twitter
decided to suspend the New York Post
account for weeks because they refused
to delete this uh information you
couldn't even find the front page of the
paper on on Twitter
um I found that an extraordinary piece
of censorship
yes and that was where we started with
the Twitter files and not only could you
not find the story for a while they
actually prevented people from sharing
it with each other in DMS which is a
tool they usually only restrict
um to like child pornography so they use
the most extreme tools they had to
suppress that story for about a day the
New York Post account was locked for
another two weeks but the as we found
out when we looked in the files the
entire premise for suppressing that
story which was hacked materials they
knew from the very beginning was
specious
and so it was a totally illegitimate
case of censorship and I think a
historic one in in American well you
know I I said to Donald Trump
interviewed him Donald Trump I said if
you just stopped going on about having
the election stolen and making up claims
about fraudulent voting and so on if you
just stuck to what happened to the New
York Post explosive Honda Biden laptop
there are polls suggesting that that in
itself had it been properly out there
and been properly examined and followed
by the mainstream media they could have
tipped the election Trump's way so in a
way that is legitimate case of
potentially having the election robbed
was that the suppression of genuine
journalism that was damaging to Biden
actually could have been contributing to
Trump losing
yeah it's impossible to say but for
certain it was illegitimate censorship
and it's been very disappointing to
watch the reaction of American
journalists a lot of whom I think
overlooked this incident just because
they don't like Donald Trump
um the reality is this could happen to
anybody and it could happen to any
journalists and and that fact
um should really make everybody in the
business very very nervous and uh it
hasn't which is unfortunate well Matt
you did some brilliant work on this I
know with Barry Weiss and others I'm so
glad Elon got you in to do that got
under the Bonnet uh thank you very much
Dave for joining me
thanks so much Pierce I appreciate it
well coming next to these schools
allowing children to change genders
without even informing their parents of
people's being put at risk by policies
of fear we'll discuss that with the bank
[Music]
really beloved and that's a surprise
they're careful who are you trying to
exactly it's just like some kind of
Submarine prime minister you're making
the case here now
a MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word pop the
kettle on this is the royal tea did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
[Music]
all right passionate and always straight
to the point world-class broadcaster
Vanessa Feltz is on talk TV every night
of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
if you're thinking it
we're talking about
foreign
[Music]
by the talk TV contributor Paula Ron
Adrian times radio host digable makes
his debut on Piers Morgan uncensored
great to see you I got a new book out
death under a little Sky which is
described probably by you as gloriously
atmospheric no by truly excellent debut
and other wonderful tributes it's it's a
totally great book I haven't read it yet
my birthday holiday today and I will go
and read it that's the birthday present
for you happy birthday thank you 68
today isn't it that's my hair did I read
that wrong good to see you let's talk
about this this gender in schools
business right we talk a lot about
gender related things and some people
get bored with it but they're a really
important principles at stake here what
did you feel sister you're a parent the
idea that a child could be at school
self-identifying with all that goes with
that with the full the school's full
knowledge and kind of cooperation if you
like and the parents wouldn't know what
do you think of that I think first of
all it's such a difficult area we talked
about a lot on our program as well today
um I feel sorry for teachers first of
all I don't know how you be a teacher in
this situation you know you come into
school a kid comes to you and says
um I might have been born a girl but I
think I'm a boy what do you do you want
to look after them you don't want them
to be bullied because I don't think you
don't tell the parents well I agree with
that I think in the end the only way
these things get settled is if people
talk openly about them that means
there's three people involved in this
there's the school the teacher there's
the kid and there's the parents right
and why wouldn't you just talk about
this stuff I've got a 14 year old and it
is very striking to me this type
fluidity non-binary stuff it's
definitely there it's there in the
school a couple of kids yeah but it's
also it seems to me like it's a it's
Paul it does seem to me like a craze
right it seems like it's a fad like it's
the trendy thing now for young people at
school to go I'm non-binary I'm gender
fluid they're all doing it right I mean
there's a school in Brighton which is
the mecca for all these things um where
I think like one in ten kids was
identifying as non-binary out of a
thousand it was ridiculous
um obviously they're not all I suspect
genuinely non-binary they're just going
along with whatever it is and lost in
the wash will be the ones who've really
got gender dysphoria right so I I have a
problem with this as a parent of four
kids if I found out that a school and
teachers were deliberately hiding
information like the gender identities
supposedly of my kids I'd be furious
you'd be furious and you'd have a right
to be furious wouldn't you do you think
because absolutely we have to understand
and remember what it is a school is
supposed to do a school is supposed to
be there to look after our child and
Care our child it's essentially acting
as a parent when we're not and it's
supposed to be there to not only
um help our child but to educate our
child now I do wonder what the message
is that we would be giving to a child if
a child came to you and said keep this a
secret don't tell my mum don't tell my
dad and as an adult you said okay I
won't
that's that's not helpful either I agree
with that but why does the parent I mean
you're a parent we're all parents
it's the parents job to know as well
because yeah but stay come on now you
know I'd love to think I'm the best
parent in the whole world there are
going to be things about my child I
don't know if it's not actually that I
was struck by the Numbers the numbers of
schools before this was going on yeah I
was absolutely shocked when I read that
report this morning well it's seven out
of ten it's seven out of 10. they only
asked 150 schools so you can you can
judge about however you like but it's
quite a big thing as a parent I mean I'm
not a very amen we all can realize our
flaws was parenting about 14 year olds
how many times did you not tell your
parents things about you when you were
growing up
the kids feel like they've got a foil
yeah they've got someone who's in on
their thing right but this is
about their identity this is not like
they might be sneaking a cigarette but
you said you really believe Steve this
is about their Identity or is it just
about joining the club I think it's
about both of the kids and
experience they experiment they're all
over the place particularly teenagers
and I think to a certain extent we've
got to allow them to express themselves
you've got to allow them to see where
they are in the world and we've all done
it now I think there is a a herd
mentality in this area but we've all
experimented at various times in our in
our lives particularly when we're young
and you've got to give them a certain
amount of space to do what do you think
about what do you think about
self-identity which is now this massive
crisis really where Nicola sturgeon has
to basically lose her job as first
Minister because she just couldn't say
what a woman is and couldn't understand
why people were angry that a male rapist
went to a women's prison what do you
feel about the the concept of Limitless
self-identity I think you can't change
biology I think it's really easy for me
as a man people I think people can do
what they want with their lives but it's
never going to really harm my rights so
they're conflicts of Rights you have to
do this all the time in law there's the
rights of women there's the rights of
people who want to identify a certain
way it never clashes with my rights
because I'm a bloke people can say
whatever they like I don't need a safe
safe space I've not got any safe spaces
that to me is no it's all in this case
it's all about the infringement of
women's rights exactly Paul I want to
show you a video clip yes this is of a
uh a coach a weightlifting coach male
called RV silverberg who decided that he
would exploit this was in Canada where
the rules say that anyone who
self-identifies as a woman could compete
in the female category so he was a male
powerlifting coach who then
self-identified as a woman entered the
woman's powerlifting competition yeah uh
smashed the record obviously the
all-time record of 84 kgs or something
set by Anne Andres who was also
transgender a man who identified or male
identifies Pizza as a woman and he did
it to prove a point about the absurdity
yes in sport especially yes the
absurdity of where Limitless
self-identity takes you yes it's absurd
and and of course when you look at that
extreme you are going to get the Absurd
of course you are and that when we are
are at the end of the Absurd we're also
not helping the people who actually do
want to identify that doesn't help them
either and so he was right actually I
think I do support him for doing that
because clearly we do need to work at
this we do need to understand what's
going on but shutting people out
shutting a parent out is not the answer
there's not a human right to to to
compete in support and I think
ultimately male biology particularly
through puberty means you have a
difference
and you can respect trans people and
their right to live a life but they
don't have a human right to compete in
female Sport and I think what we're
seeing now actually is a hardening a lot
of sporting bodies have just recognized
that that's a relatively straight well
let me ask you guys two completely
different questions right uh but I want
a straight answer simple answers
uh uh 10 years time
if you're still alive will King Charles
still be King Charles in other words
will there still be a monarchy that's
easy answer yes yeah I agree yes easy
answer
um in two and a half years time well
Richie soonax still be prime minister no
no really
I think you can just I'm not so sure I
think you can mount a case just about
that maybe the momentum is faintly
swinging back but even if he was
brilliant yes and even if he had one at
this stage in 1992 at this stage Neil
kinnick was further ahead had been ahead
in the polls longer than Kia's dama he
was further ahead in the polls over the
Tories and the Tories eventually brought
in safe old John Major yes and Neil
Kenneth got a little bit of cocky and
safe old John Major Nick tip you've got
conservative MPS now launching legal
action against their prime ministers
[Applause]
hey was that unlock would have join me
thank you Rosanna Happy Birthday Mr
President how lovely he's like come and
sit down thank you I'm actually taking
two I'm sure you'll all agree two
extremely well deserved weeks off I'm
gonna go to Hollywood and lie on the
palm trees uh and I've made the
potentially career-ending decision for
one of us to allow Rosanna to come and
sit in my chair and host Piers Morgan on
census it should be Rosanna Lockwood
uncensored which I don't even know what
that is like but we're going to find out
for the next two weeks well for starters
identify as a woman uh yes
about it but I will bring my own
particular brand to the show we'll have
some good interviews some nice
conversations hopefully a good show for
you we'll look forward to seeing you
then I mean are you opinionated I know
you're a very good business journalist
but have you got I watch your Twitter
feed you're quite gobby on there a
fairly gobby uh but you know that's just
me being a classic intro it's easier to
be gobby online isn't it than it is
person to person but in a TV studio come
on why not what an opportunity let's go
for I will be sharing my opinion some of
them are different to pierces uh you
know I hope you don't mind me saying
that but I'm a few decades I mean look
it's the normal it's the normal rules if
you do really well great if you do too
well not too good and if you do terribly
I've never heard of you
um well I'm 58 today I know you're all
thinking no really you look about 40.
um but because I'm treating my body like
a temple at the moment there'll be none
of this cake for me but instead given
you've made your debut here today you
can have a slice oh Brush Your Heart
Holy you can have a slice and Rosanna
you can have a slice uh because I'm that
kind of guy I'm all about the giving we
volunteered to come out of the cake for
you but no one no one was interested
the book is death under a little Sky I
see Gable uh I'm told by those who who
read it it's terrific so thank you very
much I will read it under a palm tree
next week uh great to see you well
Rosanna good luck next week thanks so
much about the week after obviously I'm
on alert for an emergency flying Keep It
Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read a
book
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it